IS NOW PLOTTING A BID FOR THE
SUMMER OLYMPICS.
WE WILL COVER THAT TONIGHT.
ALSO TONIGHT, THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE IS ADRIFT.
LISTEN TO THIS.
ACCORDING TO NBC NEWS, JOE IS
NOW HEMORRHAGING SUPPORT FROM
HISPANIC AMERICANS,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, SUBURBAN
MOMS, AND OF COURSE YOUNG PEOPLE
AND AMID A ROLLING SERIES OF
CALAMITIES AND SINKING APPROVAL
RATINGS, THE PRESIDENT'S FEELING
LATELY THAT HE JUST CAN'T CATCH
A BREAK.
POOR JOE BIDEN, HE'S JUST NOT
GETTING THE RESPECT HE THINKS HE
DESERVES.
NATURALLY HE'S NOT LOOKING FOR
SOMEONE TO BLAME.
IT IS ALWAYS PUTIN, THERE'S
ALWAYS FOX NEWS, HANNITY, TRUMP,
WHATEVER.
BUT PRODUCTIVELY HE SHAMELESSLY
NOW IS USING THE HORRIFIC
SHOOTING IN UVALDE FOR POLITICAL
GAIN.
NO DOUBT THERE ARE SERIOUS
CONCERNS SURROUNDING THIS
MASSACRE IN TEXAS, THE UVALDE
SCHOOL DISTRICT POLICE CHIEF HAS
STOPPED COOPERATING WITH THE
TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY'S INVESTIGATION.
THAT CAN'T HAPPEN.
THAT IS INCREDIBLY TROUBLING AND
SHOULD BE TO EVERYBODY.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY ZERO EXCUSE FOR THE
HOUR PLUS THAT IT REPORTEDLY NOW
TOOK LAW ENFORCEMENT THE STORM
THAT BUILDING AND RESCUE THOSE
KIDS.
THAT IS THEIR JOB.
THERE'S NO REASON THIS COUNTRY
CANNOT SECURE EVERY SINGLE
SCHOOL WITH WELL-TRAINED AND
PREPARED ARMED GUARDS, INCLUDING
RETIRED COPS, RETIRED MILITARY
PERSONNEL ALONG WITH METAL
DETECTORS AND A SINGLE POINT OF
ENTRY INTO EVERY SCHOOL.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT ADDRESSING ANY
OF THIS.
INSTEAD, HE'S, WHAT, PREDICTABLY
VILIFYING THE SECOND AMENDMENT
AND RESPONSIBLE, LAWFUL GUN
OWNERS EVERYWHERE, EVEN
THREATENING TO BAN 9 MILLIMETERS
HANDGUNS.
REALLY, JOE?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Biden: 26 CALIBER
BULLETS WERE LODGED IN THE LONG,
WE CAN PROBABLY GET IT OUT AND
MAYBE SAVE A LIFE.
A 9 MILLIMETERS BULLET BLOWS THE
LONG OUT OF THE BODY.
THE IDEA THE HIGH CALIBER
WEAPON -- THERE IS SIMPLY NO
RATIONAL BASIS FOR IT IN TERMS
OF HUNTING, AND REMEMBER, IT'S
NEVER ABSOLUTE, YOU COULDN'T BUY
A CANON WHEN THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
>> Sean: THAT WAS DEBUNKED BUT
THAT'S A DIFFERENT ISSUE FOR A
DIFFERENT DAY.
JOE, BEFORE YOU RIP UP THAT
DOCUMENT CALLED THE
CONSTITUTION, WHAT ABOUT WE
OFFER SCHOOLCHILDREN, OUR
PRECIOUS CHILDREN, OUR NATIONAL
TREASURE, SAME EXACT PROTECTION
THAT YOU JOE BIDEN ENJOY.
AND ALL THE OTHER HIGH-RANKING
POLITICIANS ENJOY AND HOLLYWOOD
STARS ENJOY.
THAT'S ARMED SECURITY.
AND BY THE WAY, ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING BIDEN SAID IS TRUE, NOT
A WORD.
WATCH, WILL WE THE PEOPLE BE
TOTALLY DEFENSELESS?
WHAT DO WE DO WHEN EVIL PEOPLE
BREAK INTO OUR HOMES?
HOW DID THAT DEFUND, DISMANTLE,
NO-BAIL STUFF WORKED OUT SO FAR
IN THIS COUNTRY?
NOW DISARMING EVERY LAW-ABIDING
CITIZEN?
NO, THAT'S NOT THE ANSWER, THAT
IS A PRESCRIPTION FOR CHAOS,
DEATH, AND DESTRUCTION, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WON'T TOLERATE
IT, AND NOR SHOULD THEY.
KEEP IN MIND, ACCORDING TO ONE
STUDY CITED BY THE ALMIGHTY CDC
OF ALL PEOPLE, THERE UP TO
2.5 MILLION DEFENSIVE GUN USES
EACH YEAR, MEANING SAVING LIVES.
ANOTHER STUDY FOUND THERE ARE AT
LEAST 2.1 MILLION DEFENSIVE GUN
USES ANNUALLY.
THAT MEANS THE GUNS THAT
JOE BIDEN JUST DEMONIZED ARE
USED MORE FOR SELF-DEFENSE THAN
FOR CRIMINAL ACTS.
AND ACCORDING TO A MULTIYEAR
STUDY FROM JOHN LOT -- OR
MEMBER, RODE MORE GUNS, LESS
CRIME -- WELL, THE STATES WITH
THE LARGEST INCREASES IN GUN
OWNERSHIP, THEY ALSO HAVE THE
LARGEST DROP IN VIOLENT CRIMES.
COINCIDENCE?
I DON'T THINK SO.
OF COURSE JOE BIDEN DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT THE FACTS.
IS LOOKING FOR POLITICAL WIN.
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO "FOLLOW THE
SIGNS," OR IN THIS CASE, FOLLOW
THE STATISTICS CONNECT AFTER
ALL, BIDEN CARED SO DEEPLY ABOUT
GUN VIOLENCE, WHERE HAS HE BEEN
THE LAST 15 YEARS?
TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
SINCE 2019, AT LEAST 4,642 KIDS
IN THIS COUNTRY HAVE BEEN SHOT
AND KILLED.
ALL OF THESE LIVES ARE PRECIOUS.
AGAIN, OUR NATIONAL TREASURE,
MANY OF THESE KIDS WERE MURDERED
IN CHICAGO.
WE HAVE BEEN SCROLLING THEIR
NAMES THAT YOU NEVER HEAR ABOUT
2009.
JOE BIDEN HASN'T MENTIONED THEIR
NAMES ONCE, NOT ONE SINGLE TIME.
WHEN HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT FOR
EIGHT YEARS, ALL THOSE YEARS,
500 YEARS IN THE SENATE, NEVER
MENTIONED IT.
AND THIS WEEKEND, GUESS WHAT?
ANOTHER 47 PEOPLE SHOT, NINE
KILLED IN THE WINDY CITY.
AND BALTIMORE, FOUR WERE KILLED
DURING A SPREE OF SHOOTINGS IN
NEW YORK CITY, THREE MORE WERE
MURDERED.
AND ALL TOLD, MORE THAN 130
PEOPLE WERE SHOT AND KILLED
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY JUST THIS
WEEKEND ALONE.
IN FACT, LAST WEEK'S TRAGEDY IN
TEXAS, THERE HAVE BEEN AT LEAST
ANOTHER -- THERE HAVE BEEN AT
LEAST 15 OTHER INCIDENTS THAT
COULD BE CLASSIFIED AS
MASS SHOOTINGS WITH AT LEAST
FOUR VICTIMS.
JOE BIDEN RARELY IF EVER
MENTIONS ANY OF THESE ACTS OF
VIOLENCE.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE IT DOES NOT HELP HIM
POLITICALLY, SADLY.
MUCH OF THE VIOLENCE IS
OCCURRING IN AMERICA'S BIG BLUE
DEMOCRATIC CITIZENS IN THOSE
DEEP BLUE DEMOCRATIC STATES
WHERE THERE WAS BIG LIBERAL
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATS HAVE ROLLED
WITH IMPUNITY FOR NEARLY A
HUNDRED YEARS.
ALL OF THESE CITIES, FOR THE
MOST PART THEY HAVE STRICT
GUN-CONTROL LAWS AND THE
VIOLENCE IS ONLY GETTING WORSE
AND HARDLY A PEEP OUT OF ANY
PROMINENT DEMOCRAT.
INSTEAD, THEY CLING TO GROUPS
LIKE BLM, BLACK LIVES MATTER,
THE GROUP THAT CHANTED "WHAT WE
WANT, DEBT COPS, WHEN DO WE WANT
THEM, NOW."
AND THANKS TO THE DEFUND,
DISMANTLE MOVEMENTS, NO BAIL
MOVEMENT, THESE CITIES ARE IN
TATTERS.
POLICE BUDGETS SLASHED,
VILIFIED, INSANE NO BAIL LAWS
AND A REFUSAL TO EVEN PROSECUTE
VIOLENT REPEAT OFFENDERS BUT
JOE BIDEN, HE DOESN'T DARE SPEAK
OUT AGAINST THE RADICAL LEFT.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE COURAGE, HE
DOESN'T HAVE A COMMITMENT TO LAW
AND ORDER AND SAFETY AND
SECURITY FOR ANY AMERICAN, WHICH
BY THE WAY WOULD BE THE
FUNDAMENTAL PREREQUISITE IF WE
WANT TO HAVE THE ABILITY IN THIS
COUNTRY TO PURSUE HAPPINESS.
LIFE, LIBERTY, AND PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS.
HE ALSO CAN'T COUNT ANY OF HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, AFGHANISTAN,
WAR IN EUROPE, INFLATION,
STAGFLATION, GAS PRICES, ANOTHER
RECORD -- A MILLION COVID DEATHS
UNDER BIDEN'S WATCH, HE SAID HE
WOULD END THE VIRUS.
DIDN'T HAPPEN.
NOW THE MIDTERM STRATEGY IS,
WHAT, A HEAVY DOSE OF
FEARMONGERING SURROUNDING,
BANNING GUNS, WHIPPING UP THE
DEMOCRATIC RADICAL BASE,
ROE V. WADE IF, IN FACT, THAT IS
SENT BACK TO THE STATES, IT WILL
NOT RESULT IN ABORTIONS BECOMING
ILLEGAL IN AMERICA, THEY WILL
DEMAGOGUE BAT.
DON'T EXPECT THEM TO OFFER ANY
REAL SOLUTIONS.
YOU KNOW, THE SELF-PROCLAIMED --
THE GUY THAT SAID HE WAS THE
GREAT UNITER, HE WON'T EVEN
ATTEMPT TO WORK WITH
REPUBLICANS.
INSTEAD, HE WILL VILIFY THEM.
ALWAYS, CAPITULATING TO THE
RADICAL CLIMATE ALARMIS